was mich beschäftigt ich würde gar nicht
sagen empört und wirklich was mich
bewegt und was mich beschäftigt und das
ist jetzt denken sie es wird dröge würde
es aber nicht das
bundesverfassungsgericht und zwar
beschäftigt mich dass der
befangenheitsantrag gegen den
bundesverfassungsgerichts präsidenten
stefan arbeit abgelehnt wurde denn ich
frage mich schon seit längerem macht das
bundesverfassungsgericht seinen job noch
richtig schützt das
bundesverfassungsgericht wirklich unsere
verfassen ich weiß es sind harte fragen
wie komme ich dazu mich das überhaupt zu
fragen der grund liegt darin ein corona
vor allem eigentlich ein der korona
pandemie seine urteile lassen mich
nämlich zweifel aufkommen ich möchte ihn
gern zwei beispielen das gesetz zum
schutz der bevölkerung bei einer
epidemischen lage nationaler tragweite
hatte weitreichende
freiheitseinschränkung für uns alle zu
folge es kam auch klagen ist kam
eilanträge es kam verfassungsbeschwerden
aber die wurden alle aus formellen
gründen abgelehnt und das zweite
beispiel weswegen ich mich manchmal
frage ob das bundesverfassungsgericht
gerade noch seinen job richtig macht war
auch die ausgangssperre es kamen klagen
bis heute ist kein urteil gefällt worden
über die ausgangssperren wir müssen doch
vom bundesverfassungsgericht erwarten
können es in so einem fall direkt
entschieden wird nach meinem langen
monolog sich die runde jetzt auch gern
eröffnen die meine gäste hier das heute
abend sehen auf die verfassungsrichter
noch ihren job richtig machen ich glaube
nein mit sehen dass die unabhängigkeit
von der politik gegeben nicht mehr
gegeben ist wir sehen die
verfassungsrichter sind eher claqueure
der politik geworden das hat schon
begonnen mit der ezb politik mit den
urteilen zum euro zum beispiel und seit
jahren muss man tatsächlich sich fragen
warum werden politiker ernannt von der
politik die dann auch noch ein
parteibuch haben das finde ich ist ein
großes manko im ganzen system die
unabhängigkeit ist nicht mehr gewährt
und damit ist auch und demokratie
gefährdet sie sprechen ja jetzt hier
anders professor der harvard das ist ja
der bundesgerichtspräsident
der war bis 2008 zehn abgeordnete der
fraktion im bundestag wurde von dort
vize und wenig später präsident des
verfassungsgerichtes und es gab dann
auch noch ein abendessen mit der
kanzlerin er war die welt auch zum
beispiel berichtet aber woher kommt das
dem bundesverfassungsgericht also wie
könnte man es machen jeder hat ja
eigentlich eine politische couleur
sollte derjenige dann nicht vorher tätig
gewesen sein vielleicht sollten die
bürger basisdemokratisch entscheiden
wert des obersten gerichts amt erhält
eine basisdemokratische entscheidung
sollte die bundestagswahl auch
abgestimmt haben könnten wir auch die
die richter die über jawohl und light
sozusagen entscheiden bestimmen und das
war doch mal eine gute idee wenn
politiker dass irgendwelche politiker
einfach entscheiden wir jetzt damit in
welchen parteibuch hervorkommen haben
sie einhalten davor gesagt haben ich
alles genau er kann nicht nur zustimmen
aber die bürger deren der normale
durchschnittsbürger der kennt doch diese
persönlichkeiten gar nicht wie soll die
entscheidung der gut ist und wer nicht
so gut ist also das halte ich für
bekannten doch auch in hans scholz nicht
vorher in flaschen oder frau wir haben
immer gut diese politiker sollten ja
laufend im fernsehen angeschaut und so
aber diese diese richter die kennt doch
kaum jemand also da also in dem punkt
würde ich eher vorsichtig sein ansonsten
schritte ich bin ich bei ihnen aber in
dem punkt würde ich vorsichtig ab die
lage zu jung aber was was mich
tatsächlich wahnsinnig bewegt ist das
hier ein ganz großer fehler begangen
wurde das ist nämlich dieses brisante
abendessen tatsächlichen herab weil das
reicht ja dass im endeffekt die
regierung damit auch diese das gesamte
system karlsruhe in den blöde situation
gebracht hatte ich meine es ist ein
hochsensibles thema und gerade in dem
moment wo wir im riskieren eine
vertrauenskrise in den staaten und
unsere rechtsstaatlichkeit auszulösen
ist glaube ich etwas passiert was fatal
ist denn diese vertrauenskrise haben wir
zu teilen eh schon im moment und ich
glaube es nicht gerade jetzt auch eine
große chance in der neuen regierung zu
sagen wir können es schaffen wieder
vertrauen in politik und auch in unserem
rechtsstaat wiederherzustellen
ich glaube auch dass in dieser ganzen
causa dieses abend ist eine wichtige
rolle spielt weil dieses abendessen die
nähe im sprichwörtlichen sinne im
ausdruck gegen sinne die nähe zwischen
zwei fassungs organen nicht
so ausgeprägt sein wirst ich bin nicht
ganz bei dir bei ihnen das daraus
automatisch folgt weil jetzt der
verfassungsgerichtspräsident oder
verfassungsrichter mit der
bundeskanzlerin zu einem
gedankenaustausch zusammen kommen
urteilen
nur noch urteilen die nur noch so wie es
der kanzlerin passt ich glaube als
gesteckt sich nicht mit meinem eindruck
von der persönlichkeitsstruktur von
hohen richtern die schon eine so extrem
wenn man sagt egoistische und selbst
verherrlichende dann ist man manchmal
noch ganz charmant also die haben schon
eine gute meinung von sich und ich
glaube die haben auch die meinung es ist
uns doch egal wer neben oder über uns
bundeskanzlerin ist über uns gibt es
sowieso keine kanzlerin sondern wir sind
die letzte instanz er den weg würde ich
nicht mitgehen die auffälligkeiten in
dem genannten fall müssen uns aber
sozusagen sensibel dafür machen dass wir
nicht wirklich auf die von ihnen
vorgetragene idee kommen dass die
demokratie gefährdet ich finde auch mit
der formulierung ich finde ich als
mahnung richtig aber ich würde in gegen
akzent setzen dass es schon geschehen
ist also ich glaube nicht dass die
demokratie dadurch schon gefährdet ist
die pandemie mit all ihren collateral
effekten hat aber dazu beigetragen das
ist geschehen könnte und das konnte ich
mir vor der pandemie nicht vorstellen
das ist das was mir sorge macht und da
ist das ein wichtiger aspekt ja also ich
würde auch tatsächlich sagen dass wir
jetzt den letzten jahren gesehen haben
vor allem die korona maßnahmen das
vertrauen in die institution immer
weiter abgenommen hat dass er regiert
praktisch und es war gab
verfassungsbrüche muss man ganz klar
sagen also die ausgangssperre zum
beispiel in bayern die waren nicht recht
und ist es bis jetzt ja obwohl die
klagen liegen seit april fechten sie
haben einen ausgangssperren ist auch das
wichtigste anliegen seit april farbe auf
der die geschwindigkeit von
gerichtsurteilen insbesondere von
höchsten gerichten ist ja eine viel
diskutierte immer wieder diskutierte
sache sie kommen logischerweise immer zu
spät weil es ja eben nicht so ist dass
ein gesetz vom bundesverfassungsgericht
erst freigegeben werden muss sondern es
urteilt danach sozusagen und die
zeitspanne und das ist eigentlich der
kritikpunkt ich bin nicht sicher ob man
es an dem man fest machen kann und an
einem sommer mal befangenheit vorwurf
dass man aber auf jeden fall sagen kann
ist dass wenn in der pandemie
geschwindigkeit gefordert ist dann ist
sie auch bei urteilen gefordert ich kann
nur sagen wenn während der gesamten
pandemie ist nicht möglich war dass
montag die korrekten zahlen vorliegen
weil die gesundheitsämter wochenende
nicht arbeiten dann ist es fast zu viel
verlangt vom verfassungsgericht
schneller zu sein aber wir müssen
natürlich aufpassen dass wir tatsächlich
auch nicht eine krise komplett
herbeireden auf grundlage eines einzigen
abendessens wir haben irgendwie eine
gewaltenteilung ich finde wir haben
einen rechtsstaat der vorbildlich agiert
der auch in vielen fällen und ich würde
mal sagen nicht nur in der mehrheit
sondern fast allen fällen vernünftig
agiert und gerade dieses vertrauen in
die verfassungsgericht und generell in
unsere richterinnen und richter sollten
wir jetzt nicht vorschnell verurteilen
und das ist sonst ein ganz gefährlicher
wir sollten auch in einem fair sein wenn
wir heute unsere
todeszahlen unsere infektion zu erraten
sehen denn sind wir deutlich besser ich
glaube als die meisten länder auf der
welt es gibt ja länder wie russland die
haben momentan 30 40.000
läufer jeden tag also in die politik hat
ja nicht insgesamt schlecht gearbeitet
dass das sehe ich zumindest so weit weil
die objektiven fälle die wir haben an an
menschen die gestorben sind sind bei uns
doch deutlich niedriger als in den
meisten anderen ländern also deshalb
nicht als pauschale kritik in den punkt
ja fasching ich kann da nicht
widersprechen das sieht schon das sieht
schon etwas merken kein einzelfall also
ich das ist kein einzelfall haben ja
drei politiker dem parteibuch haben die
auch dann nach oben kommen und fakt ist
tatsächlich verfassungsbrüche sind wir
teilweise schon länger gegen die
maastrichter verträge zum beispiel die
ganzen die ganzen urteile zur ezb
politik sind eigentlich ein skandal
und warum haben diese diesen maastricht
vertrag abgeschlossen wenn sich kein
land innerhalb der länder rheinländern
ist er zurückgetreten ist wahrscheinlich
dass gar nicht mehr weil just er muss er
kann nicht sagen was er wirklich denkt
den eindruck von ingo freyer ich finde
finde aber auch wichtig ich habe das ja
auch nicht so verstanden von nena als
eine quasi pauschale justiz stellte
sondern als eine frage als ein achtung
und ich finde es schimmert eine sehr
interessante frage durch nämlich wer
kontrolliert eigentlich den kontrolleur
genau also das oberste gericht ja nur
den luxus anders als alle andern dass
sie ihn außer von der öffentlichkeit
also uns unsere runde zb gar nicht
kontrolliert wird sondern dass es
endgültig wann gibt es eigentlich schon
mal in unserer systematik und deshalb
ist es wirklich wichtig dass man alle
fragezeichen die aufkommen groß an die
wand malt und darüber diskutiert und
wenn wenn das flächendeckend gemacht
wird dann ist der oberste kontrolleur
kontrolliert aber nur dann
[Musik]